[Music]
there's a place so powerful that an old
superstition says its name should never
even be uttered in a theater a player
begins with witchcraft and ends with a
bloody severed head a place filled with
riddles prophecies nightmare visions
lots of brutal murder a play by William
Shakespeare sometimes referred to as the
Scottish play or the tragedy of Macbeth
first performed at the Globe Theatre in
London in 1606 Macbeth is Shakespeare's
shortest tragedy it is also one of his
most action-packed in five acts he
recounts a story of a Scottish nobleman
who steals the throne presides over a
reign of terror and then meets a bloody
end along the way it asks important
questions about ambition power and
violence that spoke directly to the
politics of Shakespeare's time and
continue to echo in our own England in
the early 17th century was politically
precarious Queen Elizabeth the first
died in 1603 without producing an heir
and in a surprise move her advisors
passed the crown to James Stewart King
of Scotland two years later James was
subject to an assassination attempt
called the Gunpowder Plot questions of
what made for a legitimate King were on
everyone's lips so Shakespeare must have
known he had potent material when he
conflated and adapted the stories of a
murderous 11th century Scottish King
named Macbeth and those of several other
Scottish Nobles he found their animals
in Holland sheds Chronicles a popular
16th century history of Britain and
Ireland
Shakespeare would also have known he
needed to tell his story in a way that
would immediately grab the attention
that his diverse and rowdy audience the
globe welcomed all sections of society
wealthier patrons watched a stage from
covered balconies while poorer people
paid a penny to take in the show from an
open-air section called the pipped
talking cheering and cheering was common
during performances there are even
accounts of audiences throwing furniture
when plays were flops so Macbeth opens
with a literal bank Thunder cracks here
three witches appear they announce as
searching for a Scottish nobleman and
walking leaf named Macbeth and fly off
while chanting a curse that predicts a
world gone mad fair is foul and foul is
fair hover through the fog and filthy
air a scene later they find Macbeth and
his fellow noblemen Banquo
all hail Macbeth they prophesied that
shalt be king Hereafter
King Macbeth wonders just what would he
have to do to gain the crown Macbeth and
his wife Lady Macbeth soon chart a
course of murder lies and betrayal in
the ensuing bloodbath
Shakespeare provides viewers with some
of the most memorable passages in
English literature out damned spot out I
say Lady Macbeth cries when she believes
she can't wipe her victims blood of her
hands her obsession with guilt is one of
many themes that runs through the play
along with the universal tendency to
abuse power the endless cycles of
violence and betrayal the defying
political conflict
as is typical with Shakespeare's
language a number of phrases that got
their start in the play have been
repeated so many times that they now
feel commonplace they include the milk
of human kindness what's done is done
and the famous witch's spell double
double toil and trouble fire burn and
cauldron bubble
but Shakespeare saves the juiciest bit
of all for Macbeth himself towards the
end of the play Macbeth reflects on the
universality of death and the futility
of life out out brief candle he laments
life's but a walking shadow a poor
player that struts and frets his hour
upon the stage and then is heard no more
it is a tale told by an idiot full of
sound and fury signifying nothing
life may be a tale told by an idiot but
Macbeth is not Shakespeare's language
and characters have entered our cultural
consciousness to a rare extent directors
often use the story to shed light on
abuses of power ranging from the
American Mafia to dictators across the
globe the play has been adapted to film
many times including Akira Kurosawa's
throne of blood which takes place in
feudal Japan and a modernized version
called Scotland PA in which went beth
and his rivals are managers of competing
fast-food restaurants
no matter the presentation questions of
morality politics and power are still
relevant today and so it seems as
Shakespeare's Macbeth did you enjoy this
lesson if so please consider supporting
our nonprofit mission by visiting
patreon.com slash ted-ed
[Music]